would you like guys like a rap about
atlanta
i beg your pardon atlanta atlanta what
about atlanta
what the specific part of that
chicken and waffles i guess it's a food
but it comes under the subsection of
atlanta culture so i will accept chicken
and waffles yes if you have a particular
chicken waffles establishment that you
like the only one i know is in l.a i've
been to roscoe i said i'd go to it
sounded like a regularly girl i didn't i
went
[Music]
[ __ ]
cool so chicken and waffles in atlanta i
like it let's come to this kind of
trapezoidal is that the shape i'm
drawing uh this polygonal arrangement
arsenal so i'm kind of done with rapping
about like
you know no one in america gives a [ __ ]
about the premier league and
it is annoying and i'd love to rap about
chelsea because thomas two girls aren't
gonna turn around but it feels like well
that's person booed i feel like a girl
alienated last portion of the room you
need to yeah i was good good no one's
ever said that they said dmt which is 50
of the constituent components but i
don't ask you if it does work right
you've had some thinking time and just
know if it's your first thought it's
going to have been suggested before
let's get that third suggestion from
this triangle
tourists in
camden cool area of london in north
london uh not new chelsea that's in
stanford but okay cool
[Music]
far too long to get all these
suggestions so a pound of ground beef in
cellophane which is a really lovely
suggestion um
final dark corner what would you like to
wrap about
there were two new jerseys too boring
what did you say
no that's too meta because i i've
referenced soccer
chinese farmer at 800 a.d
okay cool
did they were using i guess the western
calendar on the chinese people they
would have used
whatever the day in the life
i feel like really you're all kind of
grouped against me being like well we
don't like that it took so long to get
them to rejected so many we wanted to
wrap up new jersey and chelsea you
didn't
it's uh it's going to be really fun
though to remind you the suggestions um
are a day in the life of the chinese i'm
unlocking this my phone not googling
what happened to china
a day in the life of a chinese rice
farmer i forgot molly's right now a
ground beef wrapped in cellophane
ayahuasca not chelsea football club um
your one word what was it
imagine chicken novels and then the
other
[Music]
i'm glad you're excited because it feels
like quite a long build up something
that you're probably thinking is going
to be [ __ ]
it'll be really fun um this is a kind of
sunday night people which means a little
bit chill but it's still gonna be nice
yeah it's gonna be good
combination of the food makes video when
i think about it no worries beekeeping
chill i'll be over there getting the
little waffle and machine got the batter
and i'm feeling so keen i can clean meet
you from georgia down south you like the
waffle and the chicken and the syrup in
your mouth
shut up but that's fine i'm off to
zach's beans with my mates got the
chicken and waffles i'll serve it up on
the plate make sure it's fresh spicy
where my head is i like to get a batter
brine before it's breaded and maybe get
a
i admire all the hustle that you see on
the corner i adore this but one thing i
dislike encounters the tourists they get
confused they're like okay i'm so
confused because it's one way entry to
the tube station they got an entry from
two sides
[Music]
[Music]
you a bit more historical context what
would happen if i rap about this next is
a guy in a little rice paddy he's a
baddest yeah i really wanted to go
badly but don't worry this ain't now
it's not 70 years ago it's not the plans
buying mao this is but
getting all the right sifting it is like
here i take it back there to my village
i've got a little basket for the brain
i'm gonna fill it
i really don't know much about the
general context when it comes to the
years but maybe i could inspect it later
it's really fine he'd be wealthy and all
of the grades and he'd probably support
chelsea
we switched my expectations on that
pitch they got to kill at the side owned
by abramovich that's a russian oligarch
involved with the kgb in the past so
it's kg to see and here's a little thing
i might ask you have you been to south
america
being with the shaman in the amazon
jungle you're like oh we sat down in a
circle and felt humble it turned out
[Music]
it's really
[Music]
our belief we'd never go out and
slaughter all the beef but if you're in
america maybe down south in texas you
grab the little cattle and his mouth
gets stunned with the gun you bring it
right behind you hang it in the abattoir
put it through the grinder
that's mad cow disease that's cjd it
happened in the uk in the 90s but keep
it nice and fresh not in tupperware you
open up the cellophane and drop the
ground beef in there